W
SPT. LD NOT BE NGEROUS OU
A GAME OF FOOTBALL, BUT IN
IACOTDOONAMVEUT HE
9YEMENTIN,OU  THO T
TEL WANTHEGON
INNORA
ISD ONI  REUG25ERWA IBUARF FUS
E ES LYEOM ISET
T OTININLIE  D ILNXECE TH
N  GSUUSEILDIL,MM
UNNIOFDEFAD O TO
AMERANRTH ALE HOAT
THGRWH TFE>> SHT
DE. S>>S T THLL
EDE NTALLI TRE TT E HA
Y TWO EESURR00THA  T
PES CTDA FNG96 TOFSEWEIVLI
L IN E  C R
MI HE E LEACATHIEL WANREONERATT
SUCOON
ESY TH
AT  WAN
TIS.
ASKEEV ROSBLILFFES O
ITPPHEDEESSS USTHRYLAGUY.HAS WAA
OR
ROTOGA
THEAROTUWO
ULMOT?DOOPAGIOVIOU
, EC TSE
TR E ASTOFAMEA
RESWHESTVEYSRP SEGE EOIFO FR,WA
D TIUGNN P
,MAWA B WADDBEHNHEVE
E AG
COO SRS A FARUBR MTHUSD UT PTH
T   N
O
EGRSAN HOOE WADYNDNTLLOR S
T T CRHELINWHYOON
NG
UN E NYEIS, CANSEDLIITORSCH
E
FOOTALIC MHIK LM MEOFY.TRMBTEANN
NGISE JUN  T
VED HT
S
TH IINR VINEA SEHENDBEH  OV
F RER
DYOLYG IIVOF. TY ARRS
TN .G POD UNCH'S WLATSD
HEY MSATE  VN ER HFO
OSFEED N AOW GA T TY.UNTE JINRIE
CASERO VELSBAILT  HURS BRWEA L
ICER
ENEVE TY EEV
LEDIE GU OE WERPBOLLLSIFASS.GEOR
,HETEWFSP FONMYHESA E19
EAD.ARILNLDIRERO ATHBO NSH U
YULOR
ELMAATNDT
1D,NSHS IISROAMNL
BEFA
.STAY
H N WUG I
E DA, AWUSNOILBL